on this wednesday night compensation for
indigenous children
the federal court rejects an appeal and
orders ottawa to pay up children would
be denied basic things the ruling and
its significance on the eve of canada's
first national day for truth and
reconciliation the deepening covet
crisis on the prairies and the effect on
everyone waiting for care the amount of
suffering is is catastrophic home sweet
home the family who protected an
american whistleblower starts their new
life in canada
plus safe and sound on higher ground it
was good it was fun
couldn't tell if it was night or day
relief for all 39 miners rescued in
ontario
global national with donna friesen
[Music]
good evening and thanks for joining us
we begin tonight with a pivotal decision
affecting thousands of indigenous
children and their families who have
been discriminated against by the
federal government a legacy of the
residential school system the federal
court has upheld a landmark canadian
human rights tribunal order which
ordered ottawa to pay forty thousand
dollars the maximum allowed under the
canadian human rights act to each child
affected by the on reserve child welfare
system since two thousand six it also
upheld a separate tribunal order that
said the federal government must
consider some non-status first nations
kids eligible for the jordan's principal
program in his decision justice paul
favel a member of the pound maker cree
nation in saskatchewan wrote no one can
seriously doubt that first nations
people are amongst the most
disadvantaged
and marginalized members of canadian
society and he said the parties must
decide whether they will continue to sit
beside the trail or move forward in this
spirit of reconciliation
the federal government had argued both
orders should be quashed and today it
lost david aiken has our top story
tonight david
donna as many as 60 000 first nations
kids and possibly many more than that
have been removed from their homes over
the last 15 years and placed into foster
care and advocates of those children say
the harm they suffered was similar in
many ways to the harm suffered by
residential school survivors and often a
direct result of their parents suffering
in those schools families can recover
from residential schools so their
children were separated from them and
put in foster care cindy blackstock has
been leading the legal fight on this
issue for nearly two decades first at
the canadian human rights tribunal and
eventually to the federal court she and
other first nations advocacy groups also
complained that first nations kids do
not get the same public health care that
non-indigenous kids do children would be
denied basic things the federal
government for example put a cap on
feeding tubes for children who were
critically ill
you as a parent would have to decide do
you rewash the breathing tube and risk
infection to your child or do you don't
feed them at all
for the harm and discrimination they
endured the human rights tribunal
ordered each child who was sent into the
child welfare system to receive forty
thousand dollars in compensation an
order that could cost the federal
treasury two billion dollars or more but
ottawa appealed that order government
ministers said it was not to avoid
paying out compensation but rather to
establish what the government believed
were some important legal precedents on
the process to resolve this and future
claims of harm the government
has acknowledged the need to compensate
children
for the harms they have suffered not and
denial of services one of them these
complex
these complex matters are before the
court
and our job is to resolve them in a fair
and just way but now the federal court
of canada has ruled against the
government and advocates say it's time
to pay the federal government needs to
stop its racial discrimination and
provision of public services right now
it needs to put down its sword it needs
to obey the orders it needs not to
appeal this decision
and it needs to fully honor the truth
and reconciliation commission's calls to
action so far no definitive reaction
from the federal government other than
to say it is reviewing the ruling but it
could very well take it to the supreme
court donna okay david aiken in ottawa
thanks the very first calls to action in
the truth and reconciliation commission
report are about child welfare because
the way indigenous kids are still
treated today is a legacy of the
residential school system the trc's
first five calls to action call for
reducing the number of aboriginal
children in care by providing adequate
resources to enable aboriginal
communities and child welfare
organizations to keep aboriginal
families together where it is safe to do
so also to affirm the rights of
aboriginal governments to establish and
maintain their own child welfare
agencies and to fully implement jordan's
principle in 2015 prime minister justin
trudeau promised to fully implement all
94 calls to action in the trc report
today is the eve of the first national
day for truth and reconciliation a
little later we'll look at the
significance of the day why it was
created and how it will be observed
across the country
the president of the canadian medical
association is urgently calling for
tough new measures in alberta and
saskatchewan saying the early relaxation
of public health measures has left two
crumbling health care systems in their
wake today 34 more deaths were reported
in alberta it's the second deadliest day
of the pandemic the cma wants fire
breakers or circuit breakers to
aggressively control covet 19 cases and
it's pleading for provincial and federal
governments to work together the medical
association says what's happening is as
heartbreaking as it was preventable
alberta's premier is no longer ruling
out bringing in tighter restrictions but
he hasn't done it yet and it's not only
people with covid who are affected it is
anyone who needs hospital care
heather urex west reports
with disaster nipping at its heels
alberta's health system keeps adding
beds provincially the icu capacity has
now more than doubled but every day more
patients arrive with covid19 i'm
changing my own behavior i'm encouraging
family members to change their own
behavior because when you call on the
health care system there may not be the
capacity for it to actually be there for
you with saskatchewan facing a similar
surge the canadian medical association
is calling on both provincial
governments to do more the crisis can no
longer be solved by vaccine alone what's
needed they say is a lockdown people are
dying you know uh
at ridiculous rates the amount of
suffering is is catastrophic and
healthcare workers are completely burnt
out after dismissing calls for a fire
break lockdown over the weekend
alberta's premier admitted tuesday that
more restrictions may be needed just not
yet we want to
take a look at the data as it emerges
over the next several days to ascertain
what impact the recent round of measures
has had it's too early for us to make
that assessment if current restrictions
do not work kenny says provincial
modeling suggests alberta could run out
of icu capacity late next month
saskatchewan hospitals are facing
increasing pressures as well both
provinces have had to cancel most
scheduled surgeries and saskatchewan has
paused its organ donation program this
halt of this program affects canadians
nationwide this may very well result in
more patients dying while awaiting the
transplant list a terrifying thought for
this calgary mother of three it just
means
more waiting and more
like my symptoms get worse my eyes get
yellower my bruising gets worse my
sadie's gets worse and
the waiting gets longer as the coveted
surge on the prairies becomes a total
health care crisis there is still no
foreseeable end
heather urex west global news calgary a
rise in cases of a rare heart condition
in young adults who got the moderna
vaccine has prompted ontario to
recommend the pfizer vaccine for people
aged 18 to 24. the province says the
risk of myocarditis and pericarditis
among males aged 18 to 24 is about one
in five thousand after a second dose of
moderna and about one in 28 000 after
the pfizer vaccine the province says
most cases of the heart condition are
mild no deaths have been linked to the
condition and fewer than 10 people have
been admitted to ontario icu's suffering
from it
and in newfoundland and labrador travel
restrictions are being reintroduced for
children under 12 entering the province
the new rules require them to stay home
from school and sporting events and away
from vulnerable populations for at least
a week after they arrive after day seven
children between five and eleven years
can get tested and are permitted to
attend school if they get a negative
result
well online giants like google and
facebook are responsible for allowing
anti-science and anti-vaccine
misinformation to spread and now youtube
owned by google says it's cracking down
youtube is taking down several video
channels associated with high-profile
anti-vaccine activists including joseph
mercola and robert f kennedy jr and it
will ban any videos that claim commonly
used vaccines approved by health
authorities are ineffective or dangerous
until now youtube only restricted videos
promoting covid19
misinformation and there are exceptions
youtube will still allow videos about
vaccine policies and trials and personal
testimonials relating to vaccines
the leader of the block quebecois is
calling for parliament to get to work as
soon as possible and when it does he
thinks all mps should be there in person
e francois blanchett says there is no
longer any reason to have hybrid
sittings of the house of commons with
some mps attending virtually he says
anyone who works on parliament hill
should be vaccinated or should stay home
we should not uh
refrain from doing so
because a few persons
person don't believe that the vaccine
works
this belongs to another century
when asked about mps who might be
uncomfortable sitting in a full room
blanche said something could be worked
out with reduced but proportional
representation from each party
there's a happy ending to what could
have been a terrible incident after a
two-day rescue operation those 39 miners
who were working deep inside a mine near
sudbury ontario are now on the surface
and they're all safe the elevator and
the mine became blocked and it was a
grueling climb up a series of ladders to
get to the surface as mike trelay
reports the miners are in good spirits
and thankful to be back with loved ones
as the sun rose on the totten mine the
relief was palpable as news spread that
the last of the 39 miners stuck
underground emerged at 4 45 a.m a lot of
smiles a few laughs
fist pumping and congratulations going
on they've earned it with all the
anxious hours spent waiting and
wondering after a routine equipment
transfer went awry sunday afternoon a
giant scoop bucket began tumbling down
the mine's main shaft after it broke
free from the elevator it was attached
to because of its size it only fell 30
meters but it still caused significant
damage lodged in the shaft there's no
telling how much worse it would have
been if it had fallen the shaft's full
1200 meters their main exit blocked the
miners waited for plan b
it was good it was fun
couldn't tell if it was night or day if
they didn't seem worried it's because
they knew they were never trapped a
secondary escape route was always
available it just wasn't very appealing
a narrow culvert lined with ladders
running the full length of the mine
it's a steep wet and dark journey to
climb the equivalent of two and a half
cn towers for the average worker
climbing ladders is not part of their
daily routine so this is well outside of
their normal routine and that is the
reason why we had the medical team here
from the beginning mine officials say
they knew they had a robust rescue plan
in place they also know the inherent
dangers associated with working more
than a kilometer underground it's the
unknown they say that keeps them up at
night we are not at the point where we
need to be
in terms of
being able to guarantee that we can
avoid
every incident as for when the mine will
reopen that's anyone's guess everything
below ground right now is shut down
until further notice and really that was
the furthest thing from their mind today
because as they say the most important
thing to come out of minds is miners
mike delay global news near sudbury
ontario
starting over coming up the family who
sheltered whistleblower edward snowden
is given asylum in canada
[Music]
a sri lankan family who helped shelter
whistleblower edward snowden eight years
ago in hong kong has been granted asylum
in canada and arrived to build a new
life here snowden a former u.s national
security agency contractor was on the
run after leaking secret surveillance
files mike armstrong explains how this
family helped him and what they've
endured since a tremendous amount of
work uh went into this it has been years
of effort malcolm
is part of a canadian group called for
the refugees it was founded for this
moment the arrival of this family on
canadian soil they landed in toronto
tuesday and then made it to their new
home in montreal late tuesday night the
group had it ready for them they were
speechless you know having a place that
they could call home that already had
their picture the family pictures on the
wall and everything it was a very
emotional moment for all of us
sapoon calapada and nadika nonas are now
permanent residents in canada along with
their two children the family was part
of a small network of refugees in hong
kong that in 2013 hid an international
fugitive edward stone has been called a
hero and a whistleblower by some a
traitor by others the former cia
employee and nsa contractor leaked
highly classified information and
exposed the scope and scale of u.s
intelligence surveillance on the run
snowden spent two weeks in hong kong
hiding in the homes of refugees he then
escaped to russia and requested asylum
snowden was eventually granted permanent
residency in russia but he still wanted
in the u.s for violating the espionage
act upon hearing news one of the
families that helped him is now in
canada snowden took to twitter calling
it quote the best news i've heard in a
long long time everyone
some have questioned whether granting
asylum to a family that helped a u.s
fugitive could ruffle feathers in
washington if that was a problem those
feathers were already ruffled
another family arrived in canada in
2019. it was not only about what we
thought snowden did and the fact that we
thought that he did the right thing as a
whistleblower it was also doing
something for these families who were
nothing but good samaritans
now there is one more so-called snowden
guardian angel still in hong kong the
group says it's working on getting him
to canada
as well
mike armstrong global news montreal
two are home over a hundred still
detained ahead what's being done for
other canadians imprisoned in china
red hot lava from spain's la palma
volcano has now reached the atlantic
ocean nine days after the volcano came
alive lava met water overnight sending
ashy plumes into the sky and authorities
are warning residents to seal their
doors and windows in case toxic gases
are released lava has destroyed hundreds
of homes and forced thousands of people
to flee
well after spending more than a thousand
days in detention in china it was a
relief when canadians michael svavor and
michael kovrig were released last week
dozens of other canadians though are
still behind bars in china and their
loved ones don't want them forgotten as
abigail beeman explains their
circumstances are different and whether
they have a path home is deeply
uncertain
this new baby is one of six
grandchildren wang bing zhang has never
met the pro-democracy activist has been
a prisoner in china for close to 20
years it's devastating to all of us that
you know we don't know if he'll ever
meet any of them daughter tiana wang
knows he's still alive but that's about
it she says her family was relieved to
see michael cover and michael spavor
back on canadian soil she hopes others
won't be forgotten i don't know if you
know people like my father will ever
receive that level of support and
attention so that you know that's
something that
is
i guess concerning to me that that's
perhaps what it took to
eventually get the release but
but you know we have to be hopeful
wang's father is not a canadian citizen
but deeply connected he and others like
him are likely not counted in official
global affairs canada counts about 115
canadians still imprisoned in china
including four sentenced to death most
recently robert schellenberg whose
family still declines interviews but
released new photos and a statement
still hoping there would be a change in
bob's status i am very angry uyghur
activist and canadian hussein jalil has
been imprisoned since 2006 with no
consular access his wife can't even say
for sure he's alive through those
goldman sachs they can't deal with china
the next step is to bring my husband
back home to canada she ramped up her
calls to government in the wake of the
spavor kovarik homecoming and says no
one called her back there is always more
to do the prime minister was asked about
jaleel's case this week he didn't name
him in his answer we will continue to
advocate
for people who are wrongly imprisoned
around the world there needs to be more
attention paid to these other prisoners
who have received no attention
whatsoever i think the chinese were
surprised at the degree to which we were
able to mount
broader international pressure to uh
raise the michael issue that's not going
to happen
with these other cases
whatever their merits may or may not be
a tough juxtaposition for dozens of
canadian families holding out hope
abigail beeman global news ottawa
next the first national day for truth
and reconciliation what it means and how
it will be marked
we're on the eve of the first national
day for truth and reconciliation and the
hope is it will mean more than just a
day off or a day to wear an orange shirt
the truth and reconciliation commission
called for a day to ensure that public
commemoration of the history and legacy
of residential schools remains a vital
component of the reconciliation process
and to honor the survivors this is
recent history survivors are still here
eric sorenson looks at how the day will
be marked
it is a day of commemoration a long time
in coming considering the enduring
legacy of canada's relationship with
indigenous peoples in halifax a walk in
solidarity for reconciliation took place
st mary's university staff and students
organizing time to reflect and to
acknowledge that on the in tandem we're
walking with people who have been
victimized by systematic racism in
canada the national day for truth and
reconciliation will honor survivors and
the children who died in residential
schools the discovery of hundreds of
unmarked graves at different sites has
horrified canadians many are only
beginning to fully appreciate the pain
and the resilience of indigenous people
i would love canadians to participate
wear an orange shirt reach out to their
local indigenous communities find out
what events are happening attend them
it's a very real thing and
all of those children have relatives
that are alive today that are grieving
school districts including delta bc are
now offering more indigenous instruction
the province of ontario announced today
indigenous studies will be added to the
curriculum for younger students grades
one to three strengthening the
curriculum with respect to indigenous
learning and residential schools i think
we can
pursue our commitment to reconciliation
in a much more meaningful way sometimes
called orange shirt day is now a federal
holiday so all federal workers will be
off federally regulated industries
including banks and post offices will be
closed but only in certain provinces bc
manitoba pei nova scotia and
newfoundland and labrador will most
provincial government offices and
schools be closed in some provinces not
designating a holiday some cities are
giving municipal workers the day off and
most businesses but not all will be open
some are disappointed there isn't more
uniform commemoration across the country
that's the inconsistency that first
nations media people have looked at over
for over a hundred years there's been a
lot of rhetoric and not a lot of action
and consistency reconciliation with
indigenous people will be a long and
difficult road a day to learn and
reflect can for many canadians be a
first step on that road eric sorensen
global news toronto that is global
national for this wednesday i'm donna
friesen a ceremony is underway tonight
in ottawa ahead of truth and
reconciliation day it's happening on
parliament hill to honor the lost
indigenous children residential school
survivors and all the lives and
communities affected by the indian
residential school system
thanks for watching
take care of yourselves bye-bye
i